[Music]
hey what's up
mkbhd here and welcome to tech timber
it's what we're calling it brought to
you by the waveform shirt of course
link down below let me just say this is
going to be a pretty
action-packed month and then like just
getting into the rest of the year but
there's a lot of good stuff coming trust
me i've tweeted about it i've teased a
little bit
just make sure if you haven't hit that
notification bell on the channel yet
this this would be a good time so now
that i've primed you for it a bit
this is the first thing we're taking a
look at which is a first look
at the razer ii this is it
it's the new new razer so time flies
it seems like just yesterday we were
seeing the first folding phones
and right away now we're on the second
generation and the second generation to
me
is where the most interesting stuff
happens see the first gen stuff it's all
cool
but it's a lot of proof of concept
testing the waters let's see if this
works or not
the second generation is where the
adjustments are made it's where they
heard our voices it's where
they know what tech to improve what
design to improve
and what to actually work on and what to
drop what to forget about
so this is the second gen moto razer and
to me what i'm seeing here is motorola
really doubling down on almost
everything you can see the design
is basically the same it's that vertical
flip phone
foldable but with you know some little
dimension and shape tweaks for this one
so looks like it's about the same
thickness but the chin here
is now tapered so it feels a little bit
thinner
the fingerprint reader that used to be
on the chin has now moved to the
motorola logo on the back
and honestly i like that a lot it feels
like a throwback to a lot of the other
motorola phones back in the day where
there's always a dimple on the back
and the bottom of the phone is now a
little bit different it's a more
traditional looking bottom with the
speaker
and the usb-c port and now a physical
sim card tray
and then the button layout has also been
adjust a little bit the power button
moved
over to the left while the volume rocker
stayed on the right
nice and there's three colors now so
this is your exclusive look at
all three colors in one shot you're not
going to see this anywhere else
this is your polished graphite the dark
one then
liquid mercury is the silver one and
blush gold over here
which is all the rage and the color
moves right up into the body
and the bezels all around the display so
you can even see it from the front
you'll never not know
which color you have so it's clearly a
bunch of little things right it still
looks almost the same from afar
still evokes all the same nostalgic flip
phone feelings
but i think these are all good
adjustments and then there's a new
48 megapixel f 1.7 main camera
with ois here on the front so the camera
was a pretty big weakness on the first
razor and
from the few photos i've taken messing
around with this new one
it doesn't look like a drastic change
right it's still a kind of a small
camera module it's an improvement from
the first one don't get me wrong
but this isn't a multi-camera
flagship array with an ultra wide and a
telephoto and everything like that
it's more of a bump up in the lane they
were already in
really the bigger change you'll actually
notice here with the camera is the new
camera ui
because they've redone the layout of the
camera app so it's a bit simpler
with just photos and videos readily
accessible and then all your other modes
tucked away
neatly but you know i kind of get the
feeling that cameras
are going to be the limitation of this
form factor in general like anyone who
goes for this
thin vertical flip style it's so
thin that you can't really fit a huge
array of flagship cameras in something
like this
so it's better of course than last year
but this isn't about to jump to be like
a
flagship camera array see this the
galaxy note 20 ultra with the huge
camera bump you literally can't fit that
in the top of the razor so
it's just the lane that it's in now
motorola has also updated
the hinge here on the razor you know the
most important part
of a folding phone that helps you get
that satisfying close
so it goes from the aluminum body up
here to a stainless steel
gapless hinge now they call it a zero
gap hinge but that's not because there's
no gaps ever
in it it's because the hinge itself
allows it to fold completely flat with
no gaps in the middle
which is awesome but the hinge itself
still does have
the tiniest gap behind the display and
you can kind of see it a bit
as it's folding and really the folding
mechanism with the display moving down a
little bit into the bezel as you close
it
is still the same it's it's not a
complete re-engineering it's kind of
like what samsung did with the fold it's
just a little cleaner
hopefully a little more durable than the
previous version from last year
but still if you look to the sides of
the display you can actually see the
gears
of the hinge turning in on each other as
you fold them
open and closed and the main display
itself is going to be
a 6.2 inch oled again same shape
same notch at the top and i was actually
thinking
visually it looked like there was a lot
less visible crease with this version
but then as i started folding it and
using it more and more for a couple days
slowly the crease became visible again
in this very unique
like triple crease look because of the
back plate behind it
and again it's not a huge deal if you're
using the phone like normal just looking
at content on the screen
but if you're looking for the crease
it's still there and also i've got to
say i've always found these
a little bit difficult to quickly open
with one hand
and i think you know part of it is
because it's a glossy phone and it's a
little bit slippery
but just i know it would take a bit away
from the nostalgia but i think some of
these are gonna need like a little notch
a little cut out indent at the bottom so
it's you're able to quickly
open it and confidently not think you're
gonna drop it
it's a small thing but it would help
usability a lot
closing it is still awesome though also
motorola in their marketing language
says that this is again a uh what do
they say
a water repellent design uh and
that's not like an ip rating that's not
water resistance of any kind it's really
just saying that there are parts behind
the display that
if there's a little condensation or a
little extra moisture it will protect
those parts but uh yeah this is still
definitely a phone you're going to want
to protect from water don't go
dunking this in water thinking it's
water repellent so
pretty much everything we've gone over
so far minor changes right very familiar
phone
i think the last two are probably the
most telling
as far as what motorola's strategy is
with razer and that is the specs
and the software so the specs are
snapdragon 765g
which makes it 5g capable 256 gigs of
storage
and 8 gigs of ram so not the highest end
most power hungry chip
which is probably smart for a phone with
a 2 800 milliamp hour battery like this
but that also tells me this form factor
isn't
ready for peak flagship hardware yet
like you can't fit you just can't fit a
flagship sized battery in here
you can't fit a flagship sized camera
array
in this phone you can't fit a flagship
processor and specs in here
at least not yet anyway so that shows
motorola is
set on this form factor at least for
razer
and they're going to do the best they
can within it but what i like is that
they've put a lot of thought into how
people
use this razer form factor and the
software with the outside display
especially
is like the best show of that so there's
a new card ui here
which makes it more quickly useful for
launching apps and addressing
notifications
basically the outside screen of the
razer is definitely its biggest
advantage over something like the z-flip
which just has a tiny outside screen for
the time
and so why not double down on it right
you can quick launch apps
you can use those cards you can even
pull up a full size
keyboard and type on it if you want to
which you probably don't want to but you
can
or you can watch youtube videos on it
nothing will really stop
you or limit you here it's a whole
launcher and everything so motorola
knows that outside display on the razer
is a big deal it's an advantage they
have over
other vertical folding phones and
they're gonna make sure we can do
anything we want with it but basically
that's about it overall it's a pretty
minor update there's no
high refresh rate there's no wireless
charging no
crazy you know design change or anything
like that it's a lot of what we expected
but also
includes still all of motorola's very
underrated
software optimization still has double
chop for the flashlight still has double
rotate for the camera
all that's still here so now the
question is for the price
this is again going to be 13.99
and for this price for the second
version the question is a little harder
does the nostalgia still hit
the same way that makes you want to
spend that much
on a folding phone you know knowing it's
probably going to get better again the
next generation i know the first one
came out and everyone went oh i don't
care how much that is
that nostalgia it was powerful i gotta
have that phone i don't care how much
and so that that sold a few of them and
people like the razer
but now that it's starting to evolve a
little bit is this still gonna be a
phone you want for 1400 bucks
questions out there let me know what you
think in the comment section below
either way
that's been it thanks for watching and
i'll catch you very soon
in the next one peace
you